[Musique]
bonjour à tous j'adore venir en belgique
donc je suis ravi d'être là c'est déjà
bien donc je suis effectivement le papa
de la famille zéro déchet une famille
qui n'a évidemment pas pu venir
aujourd'hui
par contre je vous présente notre
poubelle voilà ça c'est notre poubelle
réalisée à quatre pendant un an
voilà c'est un bocal on l'appelle bob
oui parce qu'on donne toujours un prénom
à sa poubelle quand on a gardé un petit
peu longtemps un an on attend de lui
parler quoi voilà bob pourquoi on s'est
mis à faire cette cette folie las de
vivre avec un bocal de déchets par an je
vais vous expliquer tout ça parce qu'on
a passé en fait 18 ans c'est long 18 ans
18 ans dans les ong affaire d'éducation
d'environnement de la sensibilisation la
protection de tous les milieux en
montagne à l'océan campagne voilà et on
à sensibiliser un maximum de gens tout
ce qu'on pouvait les actifs les élus les
enfants à la question de l'empreinte
écologique à la question du changement
climatique
et puis la question des déchets
notamment et donc on a vécu toutes ces
années vous vous rappelez les années
2000 c'est les années développement
durable moi j'ai vécu pacte écologique
en 2006 les crosnes elle de
l'environnement en 2007 2008 2009
alors marcher sur l'eau on allait
changer la planète on pensait qu'on
allait changer les choses par le haut
tordre un petit peu le bras des
politiques
bon ils nous ont bien rattrapé après une
feinte petit peu plombé
mais là il ya une nouvelle énergie qui
arrive surtout pendant toutes ces années
j'ai vu dans le milieu j'ai vu dans
l'écosystème l'impact de notre mode de
vie l'impact de notre consommation et
notamment les déchets donc je les ai
ramassé la première fois au début
c'était au début des années 2000 avec
mountain riders je ramassais les mégots
les déchets sur les pistes de ski à la
fonte des neiges et au début de la
pollution du cycle de l'eau parce que je
vais vous donner un scoop les scellés
les déchets circulent il circule sur
terre et il circule avec le cycle de
l'eau je vous montre quelques petites
photos très simple de ce que j'ai pu
voir moi dans ses 18 ans de
sensibilisation ça c'est une photo de ma
plage
j'habite dans le sud-ouest de la france
dans les landes dans le sud des landes
je suis chanceux merci en tout cas ça
c'est ma plage au mois de janvier quand
les grands de houle
on partait grand creux un pendant
l'hiver des 10 12 m de vagues nous
ramène tout ce que le cycle de l'eau
amène à l'océan
donc voilà essentiellement vous voyez du
plastique qu'il va falloir ramasser
évidemment et tout ça avec une petite
partie infime de ce qui peut arriver
dans le cycle de l'eau il faut s'il ya
un bien un chiffre que vous pouvez
retenir ce sont 200 kg de déchets qui
arrive chaque seconde dans l'océan
aujourd'hui à l'heure actuelle de son
kilo qui sont liées à notre mode de vie
qu'on peut avoir sur terre de son kilo
qui sont absolument intolérable puisque
on est aujourd'hui dans une pollution de
la chaîne alimentaire qui est vraiment
en profondeur quand ce plastique arrive
dans l'océan il va se dégrader sous
l'effet de lieux d d uv pour devenir des
petites particules de plastique qu'on
retrouve sur la plage quand vous allez
vous baigner
et puis surtout ce plastique va se
fragmenter de plus en plus pour aller
jusqu'à 10 ou 1,6 jusqu'à des micro
plastiques et pollué la chaîne
alimentaire en profondeur alors vous
connaissez les continents de déchéance
et continent de déchets qui sont
regroupés à différents endroits du globe
il parle et les courants marins dans ces
zones là on estime qu'il ya cinq fois
plus de plastique que de plancton et on
estime surtout que d'ici 2050 il y aura
plus de plastique queue de poisson dans
l'océan
voilà un petit peu l'état des lieux de
notre planète aujourd'hui et du
plastique que l'on consomme un plastique
qui à longue durée de vie et qu'on
utilise de manière stable et rapide donc
une incohérence totale voilà ce que j'ai
vu évidemment avec un impact sur la
faune et la flore puisque les mammifères
marins les oiseaux les poissons tout ça
va manger le plastique et ça nous
revient directement puisque on fait
toujours partie de la chaîne alimentaire
alors pourquoi tous ces déchets ça c'est
la grande question pourquoi on en a
autant pourquoi de son kilo par seconde
parce que tout notre système est basé
sur la consommation
enfin je devrais dire la surconsommation
l'hyper consommation
alors je veux pas faire le débat de la
croissance aujourd'hui mais je vais vous
faire la traduction écologique parce que
c'est mon souci pour avoir un bien de
consommation il faut extraire de la
matière la planète ou donne tout elle
est d'une générosité incroyable et nous
puisons sans fond de la matière que l'on
va transformer de l'énergie aujourd'hui
essentiellement sur terre c'est du
charbon et du pétrole et de l'eau car
tout process industriel nécessite de
l'eau voir beaucoup de
un tee shirts et 8000 litres d'eau pour
avoir ce biens de consommation qui va
finir et vous le savez en déchets en fin
de vie nous sommes aujourd'hui dans une
logique de production qui est linéaire
on est très très loin très très loin de
l'économie circulaire qu'on nous annonce
comme la grande solution à tous nos maux
alors ces déchets ça représente quand
même 390 kg par personne et par an si
j'ajoute tout ce qu'on jette à la
déchetterie c'est 590 kg de déchets par
an et je vais vous donner un autre scoop
ce soir c'est 590 kg sony que la partie
visible de vos déchets c'est ce qui vous
arrive dans la main et que vous allez
jeter vous même dans la poubelle
mais la plus grande partie des déchets
que vous produisez que je produis que
l'on produit aujourd'hui est caché elle
est dans la partie immergée de l'iceberg
pourquoi parce que ces déchets sont
liées aux process de fabrication prenons
un exemple une brosse à dents vous allez
avoir en fin de vie sains en cette fin
de vie dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure
cette petite équation vous allez voir
trente secondes 30 secondes 30 grammes
de déchets que vous allez jeter à la
poubelle mais pour fabriquer cette
brosse à dents il a fallu extraire de la
matière rappelez vous il a fallu la
transformer il a fallu la conditionner
il a fallu à transporter il a fallu la
distribuer tout le long de la chaîne de
vie de la brosse à dents on va produire
1,5 kg de déchets de son celle des chats
cacher alors si je prends le btp
l'industrie l'agriculture dans notre
pays
ces quatorze tonnes de déchets qui sont
cachés et qui sont liées
individuellement à notre mode de vie et
si je prends tout ce que l'on consommé
qui vient de loin parce que vous savez
comme moi ont produit très loin
aujourd'hui principalement en chine
je peux pas vous donner le tonnage de
déchets cacher par contre ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que chaque personne
chaque européen
chaque année consomme 50 tonnes de
ressources pour rassurer son mode de vie
évidemment vous l'avez compris c'est
beaucoup trop 50 tonnes ça signifie
qu'on a aujourd'hui à crédit écologique
on consomme en sept mois ce qu'on
devrait consommer en 12
nous sommes à crédit écologique à partir
du mois de juillet alors qu'angers
comment commencer ces sensibilisations à
l'empreinte écologique à quelques années
une dizaine d'années on parlait du mois
d'octobre chaque année on recule la date
on en est donc à sept mois peut être que
je reviendrai faire un ted dans dix ans
on sera au mois de mars
et puis je dis l'équation il faut
prélever de la matière et la transformer
beaucoup d'énergie en consomme trop donc
on aimait trop de co2 ces changements
climatiques
je vous ai dit qu'il fallait de l'eau
pour ce process aujourd'hui la moitié
des masses d'eau sur terre étant
surexploitation deux tiers de l'eau
douce et de l'au delà de sa capacité
d'assimilation des pollutions
voilà notre empreinte écologique voilà
l'état aujourd'hui d'écosystèmes et de
notre planète et vous l'avez compris
c'est lié à notre surconsommation
aujourd'hui c'est lié à notre mode de
vie c'est notre responsabilité ici
individuelles et collectives
alors tout ça je vous ai résumé ça très
rapidement mais j'ai passé 15 ans à
sensibiliser tout ce que je pouvais dans
toutes les manières possibles des
plaquettes des vidéos des conférences
etc
moi j'ai pas dû être bon parce que la
croissance a continué mais je pensais
être bon je pensais être conscient je
pensais être écolo je pensais faire ce
qu'il fallait j'avais une amap 1 compose
de vraiment je pense être bon et
pourtant j'avais toujours cette poubelle
c'est à dire que j'en ai les enfants sur
la plage ramasser les déchets plastiques
je leur disais oh les pommes potes c'est
fini et puis je rentrais chez moi et je
mettais du plastique dans ma poubelle
donc je devais être schizophrène je sais
pas toujours est il qu'en 2014
avec ma femme on appris la poubelle pour
essayer de comprendre et on l'a
renversée dans notre jardin
je vous la présente nous je vous
présente deux poubelles qu'alain
aujourd'hui ça c'est notre poubelle en
2014 ont essayé de comprendre on voulait
voir s'il y avait dedans vous l'avez
compris essentiellement du plastique de
l'emballage en tout genre et à partir de
là on s'est dit mais est ce que c'est
possible de vivre sans tout ça voilà la
question qu'on s'est posée
on sait pas dit on va se lancer dans le
zéro déchet on s'est d'abord dit est ce
qu'on peut continuer à manger sans avoir
des emballages est ce qu'on peut
continuer à jouer à avoir une vie
sociale etc
et c'est comme ça qu'on a commencé notre
aventure la première année on est passé
à une poubelle à peu près tous les
trois-quatre jours un ski et la moyenne
à une poubelle par mois la deuxième
année on est passé à une poubelle en six
mois elle s'appelait martin d'ailleurs à
saper pas bob je vous ai dit on donne un
prénom c'est tout belle quand on y
regarde simon répit la troisième année
on est passé à ce bocal là c'est à dire
à peu près 1 litre en un an
et puis évidemment un côté une partie de
recyclables et puis un énorme compost
parce que
vous allez comprendre du coup on achète
beaucoup beaucoup de produits frais
comment on a fait mais simplement quand
ils seront trouvés devant cette poubelle
en 2014 on s'est dit waouh
quelle est la solution on a regardé
chaque emballage un parent de poules qui
ont trouvé un couteau
et puis ben la solution c'est simple si
vous voulez pas le déchet dans votre
poubelle ne l'achetez pas voilà ce merci
ne l'achetez pas refuser le est par
contre du coup la deuxième question
c'est comment le remplacer
quelle solution j'ai donc on a cherché
pour chaque aliment pour chaque chose
qu'on avait chez nous chaque bien
comment le remplacer sans avoir un
déchet en fin de vie et puis évidemment
on s'est posé la question est ce que
j'en ai vraiment besoin parce qu'on est
dans une société de surconsommation nous
consommons trop vous le savez et il a
fallu qu'on réduise si on veut pas le
déchet dans notre poubelle à la fin de
vie il faut posséder moins
donc du coup on s'est mis dans une
démarche de désencombrement de
minimaliste de minimalisme on a tout
vendu
on a fait des vide greniers pendant deux
ans et demi et on a vraiment liquides et
tout ce qu'on possédait pour vraiment
avoir l'essentiel pour éviter de l'avoir
dans la poubelle
et puis quand on a dû consommer on s'est
posé la question de la durabilité
aujourd'hui vous savez qu'on est dans
une logique d'obsolescence tout et
obsolescence
en fait les trois mâles m3 mamelles de
la consommation aujourd'hui c'est la pub
le crédit et l'obsolescence donc pour
lutter contre ça on s'est dit on va
falloir qu'on achète des produits qui
dure quand un produit dure vingt ans
vous avez tant de la martyre au niveau
écologique
donc on s'est mis à acheter des choses
durable labellisé évidemment pour
limiter l'impact à la production
réparable ou encore allonger la durée de
vie et puis surtout en fin de vie
qu'elle soit vertueuse c'est-à-dire
recyclables et on a appliqué sa à tous
les pans de notre vie alors je vais
juste vous en présenter un puisque j'ai
pas le temps aujourd'hui mais vous
présenter les courses l'alimentation
vous avez compris aujourd'hui
l'alimentation génère énormément
énormément d'emballage puisque c'est un
système mondialisé votre oeil hour va
être produit en pologne
vos tomates en andalousie votre ketchup
en turquie et c'est donc l'emballage est
la clé de ce système agroalimentaire
pour sortir de l'emballage on a donc
choisi d'avoir un petit kit de course un
cabas des boîtes en verre des petits
sacs en tissu est d'abord d'aller chez
notre maraîcher
c'est à dire de faire la part belle aux
circuits courts
d'acheter des fruits et des légumes une
belle cage à être 50 60 euros pour la
semaine avec nos yeux
et puis après on va dans notre magasin
de vrac avec notre sac en tissu
on prend nos farine nos pattes nos frise
nos fruits secs tout ce dont on a besoin
pour pour manger et puis ensuite avec
nos petites boîtes en verre on va chez
notre chez nos commerçants à notre
fromage notre beurre tout ça on nous met
dans la petite boîte qu'on peut ranger
dans notre pareil pour la viande est
comme ça on a éliminé tous les
emballages et tous les contenants et ô
miracle au passage ce qui est génial
c'est qu'on a re découvert le goût le
goût de l'alimentation quand vous
achetez votre beurre à la motte c'est
pas un beurre sur emballés de grandes
surfaces
en tout cas nous les grandes surfaces
aujourd'hui on n'y va plus on est sorti
du grand système industriel de la grande
distribution et au passage vous allez
voir on a gagné beaucoup de choses je
vous montre ça en images c'est plutôt
beau la belle cage est le beurre la
crème fraîche le fromage et puis chez
nous on joue à la famille molson avec
les bocaux avec tous les produits dedans
je monte à l'échelle pourrait chercher à
manger dans la cuisine voilà comment on
a fait je vous montre juste
l'alimentation mais on appliquer ça à
tous les pans de notre vie quotidienne
pour éliminer un maximum de déchets
aujourd'hui on a quasiment on est
quasiment arrivés à trouver les
solutions pour tous il nous reste
quelques petites choses que la société
nous donne pas en terme de solution je
pense par exemple au verre recyclé
levèrent c'est peut-être bien en tout
cas c'est très énergivores la chaîne de
vie faudrait mieux avoir des consignes
j'ai pas de consigne là où j'habite donc
j'ai encore ces bouteilles de verre les
médicaments des médicaments les petites
tablettes en aluminium plastifiée ne se
recyclent pas donc elles finissent bay
dans mon beau câbles etc
et puis surtout le grand problème qu'on
a tous aujourd'hui mais je développerai
pas qu'ils sont l'ordinateur le
téléphone et la voiture et dont on est
tous archi dépendant voir addict 1
qu'est ce que ça nous a apporté ce mode
de vie jouent les dix au départ vous
voulez éliminer le déchet on voulait
éliminer ce plastique de notre poubelle
et puis on a voulu une mesure est donc à
la fin de six ans de cette aventure
on a fait notre empreinte carbone on a
fait notre empreinte écologique
notre empreinte en eau et notre
empreinte épargne avec ses 4 empruntons
voulait mesurer si notre mode de vie
finalement zéro déchet a été beaucoup
plus soutenable pour notre planète
voilà je vous ai mis l'empreinte carbone
ou miracle quand on arrête de consommer
quand on consomme d'occasions quand on
consomme locale on passe sous la barre
des 75 kg équivalent carbone par
personne et par an qu'il faudrait tout
ce qu'on passe pour avoir un impact
limité en termes de réchauffement
climatique quand on mange bio local
saison quand on a un circuit court ont
des carbones son assiette
on passe encore sous la petite barre des
cent soixante quinze pour l'alimentation
vous l'avez compris autre grand problème
aujourd'hui c'est le transport est pour
l'instant j'habite en campagne en france
et j'ai pas de solution rappelez-vous le
titre ice bergues
je vous disais 590 kg de déchets
produits égale 50 tonnes de ressources
consommées
si j'arrête mais logique de
surconsommation si j'ai plus que un
bocal en fin d'année un petit kilo de
déchets évidemment je ne consomme pas 50
tonnes de ressources
évidemment je n'aimais pas autant de co2
je ne rêve pas autant d'eau en gros en
faisant du zéro déchet nous avons une
démarche de transition écologique et
nous avons attaqué limiter notre
empreinte écologique sur la planète
ça nous a aussi permis de faire beaucoup
d'économies en deux ans on a calculé qu
on avait économisé 30% sur notre budget
annuel familial 30% c'est un beau temps
partiel surtout on est passé en bio
local saison voilà si vous voulez manger
bio je voulais dit la clé c'est d'aller
acheter des fruits et légumes et d'aller
chez un maraîcher en circuit court
et puis surtout on protège notre santé
on a des toxi fier complètement notre
alimentation nos produits d'hygiène
notre cosmétiques
donc on a enlevé toute cette chimie qui
est toxique et qui va aujourd'hui
générer un maximum de maladies qu'on dit
de civilisation on a fait aussi du bien
notre moral parce que de trouver des
solutions quotidien détracteurs de créer
du lien social avec des circuits courts
et des gens du territoire
mais tout ça ça fait beaucoup de bien au
moral on se dit voilà je subis pas je
peux être une part de la solution je
peux être le colibri qui va limiter son
empreinte et ça ça fait beaucoup
beaucoup de bien au moral
et puis enfin quelque chose dont on ne
s'attendait pas au départ on ment en
mangeant locale en consommant local en
allant sur des circuits courts on
favorise une autre
nomi on sort de l'économie mondialisée
dont on subit aujourd'hui tous les
conséquences et on va vers une démarche
de relocalisation de ses achats une
économie locale et résiliente
voilà nous avons un pouvoir aujourd'hui
nous avons de pouvoir changer les choses
et d'être les colibris du changement
c'est notre pouvoir d'achat et ce
pouvoir d'achat il faut pas de mesure en
quantité de choses consommer mais plutôt
en qualité comment je consomme à qui je
donne mon euros si je donne à mon
maraîcher bio local saison je suis
acteur du changement et 7 euros là c'est
à nous de décider à qui on a envie de le
donner et puis pour conclure j'ai pas
perdu en confort
j'ai même gagné en qualité de vie je
voulais dire j'ai gagné du temps j'ai
gagné de l'argent j'ai économisé
beaucoup de choses j'ai protéger ma
santé j'ai favoriser l'économie locale
et c'est en faisant de la sobriété
volontaire j'ai gagné en qualité de vie
et ça ça rend heureux
merci à vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]